thank you labrie for inviting me to
present
my name is banal sarami i'm a
pharmacogenomics medical science liaison
at
althea dx and a clinical research
consultant at washington university
where with our grants we help out older
adults with their medications
who are homebound and also a host to a
largest pharmacy podcast which is
pharmacy podcast network
we talk a lot about genes and depending
on their level of activity
what can happen but i think the best uh
it's best to highlight
actual cases that occurred instead of
just situational so here's a story of a
young boy
whose name is michael adams conroy he
was
adopted at three years of age but he was
already
having a lot of mental health problems
as his mom was in a
head of bishop as a mother he had a he
had a lot of emotional outbursts so he
was prescribed prozac
um for a while he seemed to be doing
better as his dose got increased from
five milligrams to 40 min black but
unfortunately his um
he started having some symptoms like
nausea confusion and seizure
and eventually unfortunately died so
toxicology reports
found the cause of the debt to be prozac
overdose
at just age of nine these types of
stories are far too common and it's
important that we realize the genetic
factor especially when it comes to genes
that have pgx indications such as
sip2d6 which is the main main enzyme for
prozac metabolism
here's another case of david mcintyre
was a 51 year old husband
who had stage one bile duct cancer with
clear margin
not metastasized and was successfully
removed and he was finally cancer-free
he had some pre-cancerous cells and so
his oncologist prescribed
him capsida bean we know that capsida
being has a warning of not being able
um not being taken if patients deficient
in
dpd enzyme so on his seventh day of
chemotherapy his symptoms started he was
having vomiting diarrhea
mass blisters and rash on his face once
the doctor
realized that it could be due to his dpd
enzyme deficiency
which is what is needed um to break down
the medication otherwise they're
built up in the system it was really too
late there's an antibiotic called the
vista guard but he had
passed the 96 hour window of when the
antidote could work
so he died at excruciatingly painful
death after many strokes
aspirations and his whole entire body
was really decimated
again there are many stories like these
and actually
one in one thousand people have the
genetic
dpd enzyme deficiency that can be fatal
so imagine with a simple pgms cheek swap
test we can have preventative
tragedy
mental illness is something we can't
always see or do a blood test but it's
very
common in the united states one in every
five adults
age 18 and older have some kind of
mental illness
which is roughly about 25 of the
population so
now this does not include children under
age of 18
but as we see there are so many mental
health problems in that age group as
well
one in every seven children age under 18
have some mental health illness
the number of mental health of course
keeps rising unfortunately
especially with the covet pandemic and
it's affecting everybody especially the
elderly
depression and anxiety are highly
prevalent and although anti-depressant
medications are the third most commonly
prescribed drugs
the response rate unfortunately is very
low the other issue is older adults
don't get treatment most of the time
because there's a stigma of depression
being a normal process of aging
so there's a bit there's this big gap in
getting
therapy when medications are prescribed
they don't seem to be as effective and
create the mental stability that is
sometimes is key
so we want to get a person mentally
stable soon so they can get better
control of their life
depression can be very debilitating for
an individual and can decrease their
quality of
life increase the amount of time the
patient goes to the er
which is six times more than the general
public
it also increases uh a healthcare
utilization
by up to 75 percent
i think to better understand how
valuable pharmacogenomics is in the
practice setting it's
best to go over what the current
practice model looks like or i call it
standardized prescribing
i like to give this example of a
psychiatric office with a new patient
coming in for depression
what happens is the patient discusses
their symptoms their struggles
and the physician usually does an
assessment of the situation
and based on the prescriber's present
preference
his or her prescribing habits in the
side effect profile of the drug like the
pharmacokinetics and pharmacodynamics
and what the patient is wanting to
achieve and a medication is chosen based
on the clinical judgment and clinical
guidelines
so let's say the drug of choice was
fluoxetine since it's
very commonly prescribed a 30-day trial
with three refills given
and the patient is told to try it for
three months and come back and see how
it works for
that reevaluation so three months goes
by the patient sees no
change and then the doctor increases the
dose and
patient sees a little bit of change but
then not enough to be satisfied so the
doctor adds on let's say
uh bupropion excel for another three
months and tells the patient to come
back
um another three months so when we count
the total number of months we realize
it's been about
nine months that the patient has been
struggling with mental illness
some patients can't wait that long to be
mentally stable so sooner than later is
better
so this is the current prescribing model
which is variable
and is based on professional judgment
clinical judgment
it's mostly trial and error and on the
side
and based on side effect profiles and
the patient preference
but what happens is the patient
experiences either no therapeutic
benefit or
side effects and becomes non-adherent to
that medication so
and up to 50 don't respond to their
antidepressant on the first time
trials
uh with pharmacogenomics testing not
only are we cutting back those months
for
um of getting to be mentally stable
position
and increasing adherence there's also 52
decrease in hospital readmission 42
reduction er visit and 85 percent
decrease in mortality which is huge
and also saves a lot of health care
costs as well
pgx is a tool or genomics for short
pgx for short is a tool that we can use
to guide therapy
just like blood pressure guidelines or
diabetic diabetes guidelines
so here are some key enzyme players in
mental health this is not a complete
list
but just a selected few sip 2d6 is a big
player but there are other genes that
play a role in mental health
and have pgx indications such as zip2c19
3a4 sl6 and
slc6a4 i'm not going to go through all
of them today but wanted to touch on
sip2d6 mainly for today
and sl6 slc-6a4
is a key transporter that's targeted um
there's a target of
a lot of ssris and it's said that people
with short alleles are more prone to
side effects and
delayed responses ssri
so just to put in perspective and kind
of give a visual
uh this is a pathway of ssris but it's a
specifically um shows prozac i know
that's a little busy
slide but if if you see the asterisks on
there it represents the main key enzyme
player for ssri such as prozac
so on the left you'll see they are
enantiomer with a small portion that's
unchanged and cleared out of the body
but on the right you'll see the
f enantiomer which is mainly metabolized
by 2d6
to the more potent metabolite of the s
enantiomer
it's almost 20 times more potent other
enzymes listed also play a part like
the 3a4 to c19 and 3a5 but only
they only become important once you have
chronic dosing
when the contribution of the 2d6 is
diminished by
inhibition through fluoxetine or nor
fluoxetine
so if the 2d6 enzyme is not active or a
patient is a poor metabolizer
the the conversion does not take place
and we have prozac just accumulating on
the left
side also prozac inhibits its own
metabolism which is why it has a long
half-life
so you can imagine in the case of the
little boy he must have been a poor
metabolizer
and accumulation must have been really
huge
so 25 of all drugs again are metabolized
by this enzyme 62d6 and and being a poor
metabolizer is more common than we think
45 of asians are poor metabolizer
it's a huge percentage so i also have
the ultralapid metabolic
percentage of for the completion on here
which is on the other
side of the spectrum that also needs to
be looked at but it's not
enough to just look at the enzyme
activity of just one medication we also
need to look at drug gene interaction as
well
so this is where phenoconversion comes
into play so
the definition is that there is a
mismatch between an
individual genotype-based prediction of
a gene metabolism
metabolism and its through capacity so
in other words there is a mismatch
between
clinically observed phenotype and the
phenotype you expect to see from a
patient's genotype
there's a this is a great example of why
we don't want to interpret
a pgx report in isolation we want to
look at both drug drug interaction and
drug gene interaction
so you can be a normal metabolizer but
because you added an external
factor such as let's say smoking or even
another medication
you pheno convert to a poor metabolizer
let's say
and strong inhibitors such as prozac can
phenoconvert a patient to a poor
metabolizer
and the opposite is true also a strong
inducer can
turn in turn a person into ultra rapid
metabolizer
so we call this the blind spot of
pharmacogenomics or what is better known
as the achilles heel
so it's not enough again to look at just
one medication and see how person is
metabolizing it but
rather look at the drug gene interaction
as well again
the great example is sip2d6 and and i'm
going to use prozac to be consistent
throughout my presentation
prozac is a strong inhibitor of 2d6
and if we add tramadol let's say for
pain on there
which uses 2d6 to activate we have just
phenoconverted that individual
if the person was a normal metabolizer
of 2d6
but adding tramadol made them a poor
metabolizer of tramadol
so again 25 of all drugs are metabolized
by 2d6 so it's it's important which is
why this
um medicaid this drug is really well
studied
a lot of studies have been done about it
so here's an actual case study done on a
42 year old female who
came into her primary care with shoulder
pain and was prescribed
codeine with acetaminophen she did well
and her pain was
pretty much managed just fine so this
patient is a normal metabolizer of
codeine this
chart is going to show you the affinity
of a drug to an enzyme
so codeine was a weak has a weak
affinity substrate for 2d6 which is
indicated here as the 10
coding is also an inactive medication
needing the 2d6 to activate to morphine
to come to have the pain relief and we
also see acetaminophen metabolized by
step 1a2 but there's no interaction
there so we don't really worry about it
so months later there there was a mass
in her lungs that was found and she
needed some emotional
support so she started taking fluoxetine
10 milligrams
every day and she got increased to 20
milligram every day over the next
several weeks
her pain started to increase so her
coding dose was also increased it went
from 30 milligrams
four times a day to 60 milligram four
times a day
so now we see that fluoxetine is a
strong sip to dc
substrate uh 40 and extensively
metabolized by that same enzyme
and as we saw earlier it's also
metabolized by two
c9 but that's just five percent but
since
now there's another substrate with
stronger an affinity to
to see a 2d6 the metabolized
metabolism of coating is diminished this
is a great example of phenoconversion
the patient was a normal metabolizer of
2d6
but adding another medication made her a
poor metabolizer
so a week later she's taken to hospital
to remove her mass on her lungs and
she's put on the
canine 100 milligram given to add to her
analgesic regimen due to her poor pain
control
within just two days the patient had
confusion
hallucination and became aggressive so
what happened is that the drug gene
interaction was further
aggravated so canine is also a sib2d6
substrate
with strong affinity and so what
happened is both fluoxetine
and phlokanite compete for that same
receptor
and the consequence is no pain relief
and also since the dosage of liquina is
higher
the fluoxetine builds up and you see
side effects such as the one she was
experiencing
so what ended up happening was codeine
in flicanine was stopped and the patient
was only on morphine
and fluoxetine and based on this chart
you can see there's no competition
between the two or any interaction so
all her adverse effects disappeared this
is a good example of
again how pharmacogenomics testing in
conjunction with clinical patients
clinical history
and being mindful of the drug gene
interaction is crucial in practice
and thank you for listening